whether it's blockbuster movies
serialized TV shows or sporting events
compelling stories and memorable
characters are the key to delivering
thrilling entertainment over watches
developers have achieved this by
creating a vibrant welcoming world
filled with unique heroes that people
can identify with and the similarity
between the games attack versus defense
dynamic and traditional sports anchors
those with little to no knowledge of the
game to the action but this represents
experiencing competitive overwatch at
its most superficial to pull viewers in
deeper the responsibility falls on the
overwatch leagues production staff to
guide everyone through the hectic
moment-to-moment action to forge
dramatic stories for them to follow and
create personalities to love or hate in
this episode we're going behind the
scenes at the blizzard Arena to find out
how overwatch league is making
competitive eSports matter to everyone
[Music]
[Music]
well I think there's multiple elements
to the at home viewership experience
that have to be considered when you're
talking about
overwatch League obviously first and
foremost it's making sure that the
spectator experience of the game is easy
to follow and that comes in a lot of
ways obviously the best thing that we
have is amazing broadcast talent really
amazing men and women who can talk about
the game and explain it to you and make
it exciting to watch so we're very lucky
in that regard it is so difficult to
watch overwatch unless you actually play
the game and have an idea of what the
hell's going on and I think that's the
that's also part of the adventure and
the challenge that I was really
interested in and so how do you tell
that story on-the-fly of what people
should be paying attention to I think
that's why commentators are very
important in overwatch League because
we're the ones who are kind of trying to
point out for the casual viewer okay
this is what you need to be watching
right now and this is why so in order
for the audience to really understand
what they're seeing it's a very fine
line we have to walk because we know
that a big part of the audience are
hardcore gamers they don't want to be
talked down to but then we also have a
whole new audience new players people
who are not very familiar with it and we
we don't want to overwhelm them with
aggravations and very specific lingo and
so you have to be able to talk about
specific examples and give real in-depth
analysis that makes people learn and
understand and appreciate what the pro
players are doing and how complex it is
we were quite a number of hats when we
were on the analyst desk so the
balancing of that is the the challenge
but also the thing that's really
exciting about it the fact that you get
to be able to be a bit of an educator
bit of a teacher there was a lot of
discussions we had internal between the
casters and the analysts we there was a
lot of back-and-forth where we tried to
help each other like hey if you were a
casual would you understand if I say it
like that
so there was a lot of practicing prior
to actually broadcasting to make sure
that we're hitting that fine line every
traditional sport as well has terms that
you wouldn't
understand the first time watching it
and because there isn't a hundred years
of overwatch ly being around it's more
on us to try and explain those
terminologies as we use them so we've
had various segments on the desk for
example where we talked a lot about the
meta what six heroes the teams will
normally use because they consider that
to be the best six heroes at this time
we had a little explainer on the desk
you know you try and make it light so
the people don't feel like they're being
lectured to but instead they feel like
they're just learning something whilst
being entertained we of course also take
a lot of feedback from the audience we
we see their responses we see them
various different social media and on
websites that's the beauty of the
Internet right we can see exactly what
they think and how how much they
understood and what we actually said so
we could fine tune it day by day video
for all the effort overwatch leagues
highly knowledgeable casters and
analysts put in to telling the viewers
what they're seeing for people to truly
grasp the nuances of the players their
characters and their strategies the task
falls on the observers a group of people
that are behind every decisive gunshot
at the front of every tide turning push
and in the center of each team wiping
ultimate and just like the heroes
competing in each match the observers
have their own set of challenges to
overcome my name is Jason Baker I'm the
lead observer I direct and switch all
the game footage that you see on
broadcast the observing team runs like a
team they're all calling out what they
see on their screen they're calling out
what's important
[Music]
we watch a lot of the games the team's
led us in their scrim so we get to see
how they practice on how they prepare
after two or three matches we know what
a players gonna do before it does it the
challenges to trying to show all the
action in a game like overwatch is huge
just like real sports you can't show
everything you can't show what all the
tackles are doing and all the blockers
you have to highlight the big moments
the important areas the the thing that
the game team does is we try to build a
lot of technology and put a lot of
design work into making the game look as
good as possible
and by good I don't mean like hey the
art looks amazing I mean look as clear
as possible that you can always tell
which team is Dallas and which team is
sold and it's very clear to me at an
immediate read that I know exactly which
team I'm looking at and what hero
they're playing so we put a lot of work
into the camera we put a lot of work
into team colors team uniforms
overwatch really went out of their way
to improve their spectating tools to not
only let us chase the action but show
the viewer who they're watching there's
no guessing of oh it's the red team it's
the red team that my team that I like
the replayed tools are amazing we can go
back at any time during a match and get
a moment and watch it from a different
angle we can slow it down I've never
been a part of a game that we're able to
do that live we are able to in the
middle of the game just go back and grab
anything and slow it down like the
directors of a movie the observers are
the invisible hand guiding the action as
you see it
framing each pivotal moment so that
viewers understand and remain engaged in
what transpires on-screen but they also
take what happens both within the game
and outside it to craft narratives for
viewers to invest in
trying to blend action and storytelling
and a match is a delicate balance and
it's something that we play with every
broadcast so you don't want to show too
much action and too little story or too
little action and too much story
sometimes there's a storyline that you
want to tell this player just got traded
to a new team you want to highlight this
player because now he's playing against
his old team and you want to see that
drama but now their other tank is really
stepping up and playing way better than
they've ever played so now you're now
you're focused on this other tank this
new storyline emerges trying to tell a
full story throughout a broadcast or a
match is very important we meet with the
talent before games and we talk about
players and big moments and things that
they want to talk about and things that
we've seen in trends between maps we
even go in and talk with the talent and
say hey we're noticing this guy's
playing very defensively or they'll say
hey we want to see more overhead view on
this map or we want to see this guy's
tracer we want to see how Zarya is doing
on this meta so we just constantly talk
back and forth and we just try to tie it
together this collaborative effort
extends beyond just the observers the
analysts and the players to include the
overwatch development team overwatch
league is built on a competitive
experience that continues to evolve it's
subject to constant tweaks the
introduction of new characters that
create entirely new gameplay dynamics
and the creation of new tools to improve
the spectating experience and bliss it
doesn't make these tweaks in isolation
it seeks out multiple perspectives to
best serve its casual players pro
players and viewers across a broad range
of experience levels what's up everyone
this is Jeff from the overwatch team it
relies on feedback from the massive
overwatch community expert analysts and
the production staff to shape all
aspects of the game and the league it's
actually really special how close
Blizzard and the development team from
overwatch is working
together with the Oval which leaked it
adds a lot they basically sit down and
try to be the viewer themselves like
what do they want to see from the game
and if they see something in the
interface for example like that that's a
bit confusing maybe there are too many
numbers they they then tweak it from
their own experience as a viewer so
they're really not just looking down at
things like they're there inside of the
whole thing which makes it very special
I think a big challenge of the overwatch
league is the fact that the game that's
being played is still being developed
and still evolving I don't look at it as
a problem I look at it as an opportunity
it's very cool to have the ability to
watch a stage of overwatch league and
talk about what should we iterate on and
have a community that's very open to us
making change for the better as long as
they believe that we're making those
changes for the better so when it comes
to adding new characters I know one way
to look at it is like it's adding a
whole new set of rules to the game and
and there is definitely complexity there
there's something for our viewers to
have to learn there's something
obviously the players have to learn to
master it I look at it a little bit
differently like when you think about
traditional sports and that the era's
that go through traditional sports and
the name players like the ones that you
really remember who stand out in history
the Wayne Gretzky's the Hank Aaron's
you know they redefine the game in the
way that they played and while our
players our professional players are
really the Wayne Gretzky's in my mind I
think the heroes add a little bit of
that element as well because we're gonna
add a new hero there's a particular
player who's gonna rise up on that that
hero and it's going to be a very
exciting moment I think for our fans
there's a lot of things that we can do
as a game that's being viewed
competitively that cannot be done in
traditional sports and I think rather
than shying away from it or focusing on
those differences we should look at the
opportunities that we have and sort of
capitalize on those
unbelievable just not missing a single
shot all the difference between
broadcast of traditional sports and
eSports at this point I think sports
wants to be us they want to be as
connected as the fan base as we are I
can go in eyes of any player at any
moment I can go back in time and see any
play from any point of view they can't
do that
I have instant gratification of I see a
chat I can hear the fans I can actually
tune my broadcast because they're
cheering more for one team so I could
actually make the arena go crazy with
the broadcast with the development team
taking such a big part in the
development of the league and the
viewing experience it just makes it feel
like they really care and they do
generally care they want everyone to
have a good time they want us to enjoy
the game they want us to enjoy watching
the game and that makes a world of
difference for investors this will no
doubt have been attractive especially
considering blizzards initial pitch was
an idea without a product to show for it
on the next episode of this series we
speak to some of the people with the
biggest stakes in the overwatch league
the team owners who have invested
millions in purchasing franchises and
the managers and coaches who dedicate
their lives to running them
[Music]